i
ain't no competition in the ring
decipher cause i'm spitting venom and
i'm swinging fire talking pickled
peppers make them pay the piper cause i
might go look like a rude discussion and
deflate your chest like a food reduction
you'll be talking like you want a new
concussion to do the custom attitude
adjustments these are fighting words
better give me that respect that i
deserve for another knuckle sound which
i will serve having tipping moving like
a tire swerve out here acting bad thank
you michael jackson even got his one and
only homie capping you a phony homie now
you owe me action have him sinking tony
tony tony braxton and they all want to
talk for attention but the fame only
lasts for an instant mama got hands so
i'm ready for the picture i'ma leave him
read you could dance to redemption
[Music]
there we go
there we go everybody's here you can
hear me
necromancer zell was good baby
how i'm sounding i'm sounding crispy
hard to find what's good yeah
y'all liking the new layout listen to
calling gonna be happening soon
right now um rhodes jr versus rodriguez
is on
um
thank you thank you necro so it's not
cracking anything right i went in there
made sure that was fixed
thank you hard to find
shout out to the 10 watching now to 10
likes now yo
what you're drinking on tell me what
you're drinking on
i'll let you know what i'm sipping on i
got a little bit of bellies
mix with that hand dog
thank you thank you thank you
next next week um
hopefully next week we won't be in this
room we'll be in the other media room
and we're going to be upstairs
uh in the next room
he says sparkling water that's what's up
man that's what's up hey everybody
drinks on whatever they they need to
drink on right so um
next week y'all gonna be able to get
that phone call and then uh hopefully
you're working working
sparkling ice that's what's up that's
what's up
who hit me with that uh
i mean let me let me enhance the
situation right here
imax was good
paulo cooper was going on accu
perspective what's going on imax yes yes
yes
we outside
seeing you lifting them up right
[Laughter]
let me see
all right let me see larry shabazz let
me see let me see let me see
say apollo living life on the edge right
facts
all right
oh guinness ah hell yeah fight night at
guinness all right so right now
fortuna's getting his hands right
yo
all right so
this this this weight division is a
crazy weight division
uh i knew i definitely was coming back
for um
ryan garcia
i knew it uh
because
i don't believe in ryan garcia
the the internet sensation the youtube
sensation the instagram sensation
i don't believe in him
and i want him to start getting tougher
fights so
uh fortuna is a definitely a tougher
fight um
for him in in this stage because
i think he's behind tank i think he's
behind devin um
he's definitely behind secure stevenson
all of these younger fighters have uh
stepped up and made it to the next level
you know they got belts
you know garcia for as much hype and and
as much um notoriety that he does have
it's not for fighting it's for
everything else but fighting so you know
hopefully tonight uh he gets those
accolades for actually
what the work that he does in the ring
so hopefully tonight you know he
actually does something that's fantastic
you know let me let me know if y'all
like the overlays and and the
transitions and stuff like that
um the cash app is working so dudes can
hit the cash app you can hit the super
chat you can hit the whatever um
really the the the cash app is like for
the call-in joints so when we when we
you know hitting the call-ins and we
talking
you gonna be able to hear you talking to
me and i'm gonna be able to hear you
talking to me and we're gonna have a
good time at this this is definitely
something that um i was looking forward
to for a long time and getting that done
um
all right so right now in the 11th round
you got roach versus rodriguez roach
junior definitely has been dominating
this whole fight i was watching this uh
for a minute um he has uh rodriguez up
against the ropes you know roach does
and he's you know
orthodox boxer uh he's uh they're
clinching right now nothing too much uh
nothing too flashy but uh roach jr
definitely has a style that is pleasing
to the eyes to be honest with you uh his
style of boxing is definitely dope let
me refresh this chat real quick because
i don't know if
anybody said anything after zell
okay yeah just guinness right now okay
cool
um
nah it's
it's it's it's i love the way he boxes
rodriguez is a is a decent fighter he
does decent work
but the fact of the matter is it's it's
the 11th round if you didn't put that
road work in you didn't get those legs
under you when you're fighting you're
not going to have that stamina in the
late um
uh
rounds and
you know right now
roach jr definitely has the stamina and
he's a slick boxer puncher he's using
high guard and he's throwing hooks off
the high guard which is dope
let me see let me see the overlay is
dope combat talks is getting ready yeah
man um
i told you
what's going on all right
what up whatever um
it's
this thing
is is a passion right so my
my ability to fix it as much as possible
first and foremost
i give respect to graphic guard
um
if y'all ever see everything in the
beginning the credits go to graphic
guard it goes to dallas it goes to drum
star um drum star and i sat there with
the beat
that that was uh something that we
worked on and then we we talked to uh
dallas and had dallas uh spit over it
and me and dallas went over a lot of
things when it when it came to it um
and
me and graphic god really have a lot of
meetings on
on the direction i let people know the
direction on where i'm going with this
stuff and what i'm trying to do what i'm
trying to bring to you guys
something different something that's not
the same i know we talk video games all
day
we on twitter talking video games we
playing video games on sunday we talk
video games i'm on other podcasts
talking video games i got other things
in my life that i really like to do like
i really love these statues and i really
love boxing
they're in the 12th round right now
they're coming up they're touching
gloves
and
everybody that you know saturday night
you're drinking you're watching a fight
i'll let you boy i'm up we can talk
about it we can see it we can we can we
can have this rapport with each other
and i think that is necessary i think
everybody needs to each one teach one
get out there and start hanging out with
each other more even if it's virtual
this is this is what we're supposed to
be doing shout out to 16 people that's
watching i respect everybody that's here
so
you know what's your thoughts on the
fight tonight
who who got garcia i mean i got garcia
but
how is he gonna look the last dude he
fought
that that was a disappointing fight but
he had a long layoff so and he was
coming off of the the mental retreat
that he had to do but remember the
mental retreat
precipitated this this this fight he had
with fortuna he quit out of fortuna
fight because he was uh stating high
anxiety and some other stuff didn't did
for tuna give him anxiety because fatu
is a real duke like he's a former
champion a two-time former champion i
mean he has i think it's like a couple
of losses but
he's he's uh a tried and true veteran so
he might give him something
to you know to think about
the fight is getting ready to start in a
minute um you know we got the prelims
the place is packed
you know if anybody has the zone app go
to the zone right now uh get that fight
you know i have uh
i i bought into the zone when it was
talking all this hey nobody's gonna have
you know pay-per-view there's not gonna
be any pay-per-views
we got a canelo pay-per-view i paid for
the pavol joint so it is what it is but
uh
i
rodriguez is not attacking
uh
roach is
stalking him oh hit him with a nice
overhand right
uh he's he's swinging wildly with a left
uh roach is and he's he's hunting
uh rodriguez
it is what it is
i may or may not have covet i will
definitely get a covet test this week
so i have a
little chest coat
and
it is what it is
so hopefully this baileys and this
hennessy remove it maybe that's the cure
fawns
my dufont fonz how do you like the
overlay how did hi how do you like the
new logo what's what's going on
like
oh man fawns yo hit me up
fonz is my combat dude that's that's
supposed to be my partner on some other
stuff and it's gonna be a part in time
where you know
fawn's gonna be on and we're gonna be
talking fights man um
i i really i really love fawns i know
you i know you was moving this weekend
fawns uh
i was i was looking forward to your show
i definitely check your uh your show uh
next week when you come back
thank you thank you looking crispy and
clean fonz thank you sir thank you man
thank you i'm trying my best i'm trying
my best i'm trying to give y'all the
best of what i got man shout out to 21
people watching
this is what's up
all right so um fight is over pretty
sure that roach is gonna you know get
the unanimous decision
um rodriguez gave a good account of
himself
it's
decent prelim fights i don't really look
to the zone to have good undercards
oh thank you uh yeah i worked hard on
the microphone fixing it y'all know we
got them showing mics um
[Music]
you know uh
whatever you guys put into the podcast
we take that and we put it right back in
we don't put it anywhere else like y'all
saw the stream today it was dope
yeah what's going on gabe aka what's
good
good evening brother
what's that uh rest streambot
thank you man thank you brother thank
you for showing no showing support i
appreciate it
oh man
um
we we we're going to give back at all
times
but
who
who do you want to see ryan go see a
fight if he if he wins tonight right
who do you want to see him fight
i i don't think he's able to fight devin
haney
shakur stevenson is a weight under him
uh because
this guy he he's he's a little bit
bigger he's he's he's a big uh
lightweight um i would love to see him
fight tank
thank you thank you ksanti
yeah yeah you about to call that five
five five five five five five you won't
find me if if my phone rings at five
five five five five i gotta get out of
dodge
but i'm definitely uh soon the calling
number will be there
and and
everybody will be able to have their
voice heard and uh i can't wait for that
because i think that's that's a
milestone in in
in where we're going with it as far as a
brand and what we're trying to do as far
as a brand you know um
as as the marketing director i'm trying
to put a stamp on our brand in a
different manner and you guys are going
to get a whole lot of different merch
attic and i talk and
we're working on a lot of things for you
guys man and as far as fall guys we're
trying to get
a whole server 60 people playing
we trying to do it all man we trying to
do it all what's good all right
uh jake paul versus uh rachma yo i was
talking with cog about that cog so you
know cog watch the sensational stuff
and
i'm i'm really
tuned for that fight i want to see what
jake does when it comes to that fight
i think rockmon can get him but the only
reason why jake picked uh rachman
besides the fact that he was a former
sparring partner and it was it was
caveats because i could tell you things
that when i was a sparring partner what
i had to do i i wasn't able to throw a
jab and um it was a whole bunch of stuff
uh that they was uh trying to do uh to
me so
rockmon got knocked out in his previous
fight so
i think jake saw that and was like you
know what i'm i'm gonna have a good pick
in that fight
what i think personally
i think he's giving his friend a bag
rachman
you got to think about it he's not going
to get a bag bigger than this very early
on
and if that's your sparring partner
you'll be able to rapport with these
people while you while you're sparring
with them i think he's giving his boy a
bag and i think that's dope i think
um anytime you could break bread and
make money with somebody that you've
worked with
i think that's dope and i think that's
exactly how it's supposed to be uh
you're supposed to reach down and pull
somebody up if you make it and you're
supposed to open up that door and bring
somebody else in
let me see
uh bro google voice number yes sir yes
sir
use it for my old shows i was just about
to suggest that farm yeah yeah yeah um
that's that's what it's about that's
i got the whole setup it's not gonna be
down here in this room y'all gonna get a
chance to see a more relaxed
laid-back room and i have mad statue
rooms right but that room
is not the red room the red room is for
my gaming and that's for me to clear my
thoughts and to look at my collection
and and do things with that
the other room
y'all gonna know y'all see it and
that room
is the chill out laid back room
where combat talk could be talked about
and kos with the statues kos is coming
back
um i got statues i have a whole bunch of
statues that i got in that are unboxed
and stuff like that but
um i'm not one of those dudes that's
looking for clicks and likes and have to
be the first person to show my stature i
don't need to do that because that's not
what i got my collection for i got my
collection for me and it's more personal
so you know just like when i went to go
see thor love and thunder and i knew
gore the god but your story
it's because of the books that i read so
when i show you a statue that has
something to do with that
i can talk about it so that's a timeless
thing that's not i'm not on a time a
timer to show you my statues because
whenever i show you my statues it's new
for you and me because we're sharing it
together so that's what that's about
yeah it's a cool thing that you know
google you can call
555. call king that's what's up
i i don't think rockman is going to take
a fall
gabe i think he's going to give a good
account of himself any any true fighter
is going to give a good account of
himself what i'm saying is
like i don't think sean porter
took a fall when he fought
um
crawford
i think sean porter knew that he was
getting out of the game
did he train at his
optimum i don't think so
did he train like he trained for earl
spence i don't think so because him and
errol spence ain't buddies like that but
crawford and porter is is buddies like
that think about it because after he
lost to crawford
he was on his show the next day
one hand washed the other i got you a
bag come over this way uh
you you gotta see where the breadcrumbs
lie and and that's that'll tell a story
so
i believe that he was jobbing in the
sense that i'm out the door i'm gonna
pull you in i think jake realizes the
hard times rockmon has as far as
financially because you got to think
about his father
though he was a heavyweight champion and
he beat lennox lewis by a smooth
knockout
his father really never made huge bags
right well dudes wasn't except if unless
you mike tyson amanda holyfield and
people of those ilk um back then you
weren't making super amounts of money so
rachman got his his notoriety and his
fame through that and his son can live
off his name but his son is not getting
the brakes and now if you got knocked
out in your last fight you know that's
going to push you down on the totem pole
it pushes him down on the totem pole so
is he going to see a couple of mill in
his next fight not at all but if your
boy jake
is getting these bags
off of youtube hype and being a nice uh
instagram sensation
get your man a bag
that's a hell of a come up and i think
there's i think that's real
uh gracious and dope of them do i think
they're gonna try to take their headers
off hell yeah it's a sport and i think
they're gonna fight you know um 100
right now they're talking about triple g
versus canelo part three because canelo
can't go up against bevel because i
think bibble boxes and socks off but um
wasn't getting it taken away by your
promoters either yep that's that's the
fight that's that's right there you'll
find you're so correct um
right now
it's really in control
by
the fighters if if you have a good
presence social media wise of course you
need your promoters to to build you
these fights to get you these fights but
uh these dudes can get bags in other
ways and in other avenues so
it's a different time it's a different
age
you know if